in one of the most impressive feats of
synthetic biology so far researchers
added a suite of genes to yeast cells
that enabled them to synthesize key
opiate molecules some fear the advance
could enable people to make home brewed
heroin but others see an easier route to
new medicines it took some effort to get
through the very tight spaces in this
cave in South Africa but in the end
researchers were able to bring us the
bones of this runner up a newly
discovered and decidedly strange human
species called Homo Naledi in a win and
a loss for science the reproducibility
project found that researchers could
replicate just 39 of 100 prominent
psychology papers that conclusion
disturbed many observers but others
celebrated the effort saying it will
help improve transparency in science
these bones
known as Kennewick Man are eighty five
hundred years old using DNA extracted
from the bones scientists have shown
that Native American tribes were right
Kennewick Man is related to modern
Native Americans and now after years of
controversy several tribes want to
Ribery the skeleton
this year saw the arrival of the first
successful Ebola vaccine tested in
Guinea in a clinical trial with an
innovative design the vaccine
essentially protected 100% of the
patients that offers hope that we could
quickly stop any future Ebola outbreak
to their surprise neuroscientists found
that the lymphatic system exists in the
brain the system is made up of a network
of vessels that help clear waste and
circulate key immune cells the discovery
could stimulate a closer look and links
between immunology and neuroscience this
summer
New Horizons grabbed the spotlight when
it swooped past Pluto the spacecraft
sent back images of ice mountain's
nitrogen glaciers even a fleet of
chaotically tumbling moons meanwhile
NASA's Dawn orbiter was busy studying
Ceres
it is the largest object in the asteroid
belt and the home of mysterious bright
spots a possible underground ocean and
perhaps even life
after decades of work geo scientists
have clinched the case mantle plumes do
exist by using techniques that rested in
part on closely observing earthquakes
they showed that these vast tubes of hot
rock rise from the Earth's core and help
drive the dance of continents across the
planet's surface here's something wild
physicists confirm that spooky action at
a distance is real spooky action is that
bizarre sounding idea that one particle
can instantly influence the properties
of another particle that is far far away
the experiment embodied a test dreamed
up in the 1960s by theorists John Stuart
Bell and now the breakthrough of the
year although it's been around for a few
years in 2015 the genome editing
technique known as CRISPR transformed
science and ignited public debate CRISPR
allows precise editing of DNA this year
alone it enabled researchers to create a
new form of gene Drive a controversial
method of spreading a gene through
populations of insects and certain other
animals CRISPR also enabled researchers
to modify the DNA of human embryos that
raises the exciting prospect of
eliminating certain genetic diseases but
it also prompts ethical concerns and has
sparked great debate about how this
technology should be used in the future
you